foreign
have you heard of a dragon whose tail
releases a spray of explosive slime or a
dragon that hunts with noxious fumes or
one that vomits spiers of superheated
glass across various myths and cultures
dragons have taken on many forms but few
were more fearsome than the Terrors that
lurk within the pages of the Dragon
Slayer codex a World building project
from the brilliant imagination of artist
Sawyer Lee the volume is written as a
survival guide to the world's most
dangerous dragons explaining their
abilities behavior and how to slay them
if necessary but be warned many of these
scaly tyrants will not go down without a
fight so for this entry into the archive
we'll learn critical things about each
species that can mean the difference
between survival in searing flames and
as usual you can support the artist on
patreon and follow the project using the
links in the description now let's dive
into the burned pages and discover the
secrets of the Dragon Slayer codex
in the open Plains our first species of
dragon Paints the land red with their
terrible wrath the nightmarish Scarlet
lashers are a threat to anything that
enters their domain Lasher territory
typically encompasses wide spaces that
allow full use of their whip-like tail
which according to Legend can slice a
bison in half as elegant as they are
lethal the agile lashers are known to
move like malicious dancers the
rust-colored eggs are a prized
ingredient in alchemy and possess a
unique shape to help them stay in their
nest
into lasher's Nest is a grim sight
indeed during breeding season lashers
construct great ground nests composed of
branches bones and strewn corpses these
disturbing corpse nests aren't just to
protect eggs but to show off the
lasher's skill to a potential mate
throughout the mating period the scales
of male lashers will flush a deeper red
than usual and they scream a dreadful
call into the night which can be heard
for several kilometers Beyond mating
calls the multi-chambered Airways within
the dragon's Crest amplify sound to a
lethal degree as a result Slayers are
advised to Shield their ears when
pursuing a Scarlet Lasher yet Perhaps
the most terrifying feature of the
Lasher is their Keen intelligence a
hunting style that involves outsmarting
small prey animals has resulted in an
exceedingly crafty species should you
decide to venture in to a Scarlet
lasher's territory you must constantly
watch for traps pitfalls and other
entanglements of the Dragons making
should you survive these traps and
journey to the dark Islands just off the
coast you would face another fascinating
but frightening species one of the only
known flightless dragons the sickle
mouth or lineage Infamous for their
sword-like jaws they use these Jaws to
settle territorial bouts with others of
Their Own Kind it have even been
documented sparring with each other
seemingly for practice even by human
standards the sickle mouth is an
extremely Adept swordsman in combat
slayer's report their attacks resemble
those of trained professionals not
simply wild beasts many explorers have
been caught off guard while charting
these islands and have met their end
underestimating the sickle mouth these
clever beasts enjoy the challenge of the
hunt so if you wish to shoe one off it's
best to make your fighting seem boring
if you must tangle with a dragon one
weapon a Slayer should always have on
hand is a drake prior a kind of melee
multi-tool these versatile devices can
catch a dragon off guard if wielded
correctly but since mishandling can
result in the loss of a finger they
should only be used by trained
professionals
when crossing the expansive Sands of the
Dune sea you and other unlucky Travelers
might hear a series of choir-like calls
these aren't the sounds of some lost
musician but are the deceptively melodic
cries of wailing Bishops a dragon
subspecies common to Desert environments
whaling Bishops are famous for their
silver scales which reflect the harsh
sunlight these dragons can also vibrate
their scales while in Flight creating a
mesmerizing hum that adds to their
chorus of sounds wailing Bishops feed by
skimming the Sands of the great Dune sea
snapping up any buried Subterranean life
forms they come across this sand
skimming behavior is one of the most
unique across the Dragon family tree The
Wailing Bishop's primary food source is
the water-filled burrowing Dune mole
these strange forms of life are also
highly sought after by humans who live
in this region as well as they are a
rare source of water in this parched
Wasteland while scheming for food
whaling Bishops also swallow excess sand
in the dragon's stomach the sand becomes
a goopy molten material that Bishops
then regurgitate forming spiers of black
glass upon impact the Bishops use these
to create formidable obsidian nests
which the dragons use as a safe place to
lay their eggs but it's not a place
that's safe for anyone else
upon the stormy Shoreline where the sea
clashes with the land an unusual
subspecies has become a significant
Threat all Slayers would be wise to be
wary of the tasseled thundermall a
semi-aquatic dragon adapted for both the
sky and the Sea Rippling with muscle and
deceptively flexible the Thunder maw can
be found wherever the water is cold and
the waves are high the Thunderman's tale
is the longest of any dragon class which
continuously rides and coils
subconsciously yet what is the purpose
of a tail with a mind of its own
the answer might have to do with The
Thundermans feeding strategy some
individuals have been seen fishing with
their flexible Tails which lure and fish
with their wriggling movement a question
remains however as to whether this is
their primary hunting method or just a
curious Pastime for Thunder moths can
also hunt by sending a short shock to
stun their victims before lunging in to
deliver the final blow it's a powerful
Secret Weapon made possible thanks to
Hidden organs in the head and neck
region this attribute mirrors that of
electric eels strange beasties known to
use their electric Fields both to subdue
prey and to locate them it is likely the
Thunder moths can use their fields to
locate prey as well which would explain
how they always know when to strike it
may be best to leave these dragons to
the professional slayers
when walking amongst the dense trees of
a region known as the blood Forest a
Slayer should always keep one eye turned
upwards for the fast and agile gaping
kilnex soared just above the canopy
ready to snatch prey with their
interlocking teeth kilnex or
light-bodied dragons easily identifiable
by their slim form which is perfect for
maneuvering the densely forested
environments where they can be found
their beautiful frilled tail likewise
helps break the silhouette of this
dragon against the foliage in the blood
Forest yet the most notable feature of
the kilnek is their sheer Firepower
while kilnex themselves aren't the
largest species their fiery breath
Rivals that of even the mightiest
dragons to produce such a massive wall
of fire like a common serpent these
dragons can unhinge their jaws and swing
them forwards as aside from their
signature flame barrage kilnex or Ambush
predators that hunt using their immense
speed observant Slayers have recorded
them flying low over the countryside
snatching up anything from the size of a
fish to the size of a cow but even the
most dangerous animal's life is more
than just hunting when rearing their
young these dragons take a break from
fire breathing to carry their brood in
their unhinged Jaws juvenile kilnex have
a relatively good chance of making it to
adulthood compared to other dragons
meaning the blood Forest is teeming with
full-grown fire breathers only the most
courageous or foolhardy would venture in
on nights when the skies are darkest
Slayers who wish to see the sunrise
again must be on their guard a secretive
and cunning Dragon subspecies prowls in
the shadows black blister whips are so
dreaded that just seeing one is
considered a bad Omen their dark scales
help them vanish into the night sky
unlike most dragons they prefer to feed
on bone marrow and possess molar-like
teeth to crack open the bones of their
prey like bats blister whips are known
to be nocturnal only hunting at night
and retreating to their dark caves when
the Sun rises in the blister Whip's most
deadly ability is something impossible
to anticipate when a blister whip swings
their tail it secretes a highly
flammable green slime which the dragon
then ignites producing a sudden wall of
searing flame it's one of the most
extreme attacks of any dragon
when a dragon has a Slayer on the ropes
a slayer's best friend is a king Hound
these giant canines are bred to track
and pursue dragons with their calloused
hairless bodies far less flammable than
an ordinary dogs deeply loyal they'll
bravely protect their owners against
even the most fearsome of foes best to
bring one along if you're pursuing a
blister whip
in the sun's scorched wastes of a region
known as The Gorge lands heat stroke
isn't the only danger ruling over the
Labyrinthian Ravines or the ill-mannered
hellbaskers creatures just as unpleasant
as the environment they inhabit Hill
basker Flames are the hottest of any
dragon and are used to bore the tunnels
in which they nest their eggs are long
and thin able to be hidden deep inside
Rocky Crags and crevices within the hell
baskers territory while the Flames of
adult hellbaskers are hot enough to melt
Shields and swords in a Flash to flames
of Hell basker chicks aren't nearly as
formidable the size of small Terriers
the sandtone wormlings are Far Cry from
the tyrants they grow into when hunting
adult hillbaskers pursue Quarry into the
narrowest of canyons able to pitch and
control their aerial maneuvers to the
most precise degree in such flexibility
is necessary when chasing their
preferred prey armor heads large heavily
defended herbivores related to wild
boars armor heads have well-developed
neck muscles in ever-growing tusks to
fend off hail basker attacks the armor
head's thick skin often Bears the scars
of attempted predation which helps
determine their status within the pack
clearly Slayers aren't the only group
who have had some success fending off
dragons
at the edge of settlements one species
is known to Feast on discarded scraps
the aggressive rattle dreads or
scavengers that seek out small towns for
their trash piles led by the best sense
of smell in the Known World they forage
for anything they can fit into their
huge mall and anything the rattle dread
doesn't eat they regurgitate out in a
fiery scatter shot with this species
contributing to the highest number of
dragon attacks to date rattle dreads are
known to incubate their eggs in their
previous prey making them a much reviled
species once they hatch from their
unwilling hosts young rattle dreads grow
quickly gaining almost four times their
mass and muscle in just a few months but
to reach such sizes requires a
tremendous amount of food these hungry
beasts aren't afraid to enter Barns and
homes in search of a meal and or
completely confident around humans
you'll be warned there coming by the
rattling of their Mane of hollow spikes
a sound that signals hungry mouths in
the dark and some rattle dreads have
even been known to play dead in the
hopes a careless human will approach
one way or another these scavengers get
their meal
within the mossy Woodland a unique foe
turns the land into a Minefield the
emerald Bombardier is a relatively small
dragon with a relatively large trick up
its sleeve while perched high up in the
trees Bombardier is built fortified
nests of hardened saliva glowing chunks
of this Dragon Stone sometimes fall to
the Earth and explode under enough
pressure a treat that makes Bombardier
saliva a highly sought after weapon of
War but bombardiers don't give up their
saliva so easily and defend their
forests to the end
and there is another curious life form
in these temperate forests the
innisterium are large herbivores that
Tower over emerald bombardiers and show
that dragons aren't the only exceptional
creatures in this world their unique
modified Hooves Aid them in lowering
branches and in defending themselves
from predators their hearty and
self-sufficient nature means they make
highly prized domesticated animals to
the scattered human populations that
dwell here
upon the weathered mountains of the
coast a seldom seen creature Glides upon
The Thermals a rare solitary species the
veil right is a dragon lineage with
highly unusual features there are
multiple nostrils churn out smoke
wherever they go suffocating attackers
unveiling themselves in a dark cloud
thanks to their smoking camouflage few
Slayers have ever seen a veil right in
full likewise these dragons keep their
eggs in foggy hidden nests high in the
mountains when Veil rate shiks her
firstborn they latch onto their parents
for warmth clinging to their bodies for
a period that can last several months
Ville writes feed upon the poisonous
vegetation that flourishes in their
native habitat and these dragons are
capable of isolating and weaponizing the
deadly chemicals within fusing it with
their smoking shroud different plants
have different effects with lone War it
causing temporary Amnesia Dead Leaf
causing neural shutdown and throat Oak
causing the esophagus to close even if a
veil right hasn't recently ingested
poison their veil of smoke is a powerful
tool for distraction even an experienced
Slayer might struggle to tell where a
veil right is within their Cloud
uncertainty which can often prove fatal
many accomplished Slayers have met their
untimely end underestimating species
like the veil right whose size suggests
an easy Mark but whose arsenal of
abilities can overpower most info it's
best to avoid confrontation with these
dragons entirely
in the Frozen wastes of the far north
the slopes Echo with the call of a great
Behemoth one of the heaviest Dragon
lineages the hole Breakers physique
reflects their extreme lifestyle they
have developed a novel adaptation to the
harsh ice of their habitat pummeling it
into mist with their enormous forelimbs
hole Breakers can smash through sheets
of ice that sources of food swim beneath
their eggs are kept warm in pouches
beneath the dragon's Wings which reduces
the risk of losing them to the
surrounding ice once a juvenile hatches
they are dangerous even in their youth
often towering over adult Slayers
juvenile hole Breakers have been known
to inhabit small frosty ruins before
striking out into the snowy Wilderness
with their devastating striking ability
an adult hole breaker is not a force to
be taken lightly as their fists can
smash through more than just the ice
with such oversized forelimbs one might
assume the hole breaker would be
entirely flightless yet despite their
weight hole Breakers are capable of
gliding short distances with their
immense punching Force making for
excellent launches just as wild and
unforgiving as the Snows they tread upon
hole Breakers have single-handedly
caused the loss of many an aspiring crew
with all their incredible power this is
a species that only the most qualified
Slayer should contend with
foreign
s of the known world one of the most
dangerous species of all rules over the
skies an avalanche of muscle and Horn
the great kins Bane has unmatched
aggression and sheer strength most
stories of Castle guarding dragons are
inspired by these beasts who live
wherever they please indeed no human
Slayer has ever successfully managed to
defeat one the eggs of the great
kinsbane are as tough as the beasts
themselves with shills that resemble
bowls of iron their hatchlings likewise
emerge bulky and well-developed although
they need the help of a parent to break
through the iron-like shell great
kinsbane have been known to sleep for an
entire month while their eggs incubate
but even a sleeping kins Bane can still
be a serious threat to anything that
creeps Too Close only a fool would test
their luck around such dangerous forms
of life
with all that Slayers have learned about
dragons it is easy to feel that Humanity
should no longer cower in fear when they
fly overhead but in the case of the
great kins Bane a little cowering is
probably a good idea
the dragon slayer codex is a survival
guide to a land torn between humans and
Dragons yet Perhaps things won't always
be this way within the world of the
Codex some Slayers are making an effort
to better coexist with these creatures
and perhaps one day form alliances with
the incredible beasts Sawyer Lee hopes
to publish the Codex as a physical book
in the future and if that's something
you're interested in remember you can
follow and support the project using the
links in the description a follow-up
volume the drakenry is also planned that
will explore the possibility of things
like Dragon riding so stay tuned
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video